it really is hard to believe that Martin
didn't already have a star on the
Hollywood Walk of Fame but today is his
day and so we talked about bad boys we
talked about his iconic career and lots
of folks here also sending lots of love
to Jamie Foxx
I was just stunned because Jamie's fit I
hope everything works out I'm pretty
sure it will what kind of love do you
want to send to Jamie nothing but love
for Jamie I mean I wish it was besties
in my prayers every night he's a fighter
he's going to come out of it he's good
he's going to be stronger and better
than ever I've been there I was on the
other side in a coma for 10 days so I
know about that
and I just want Jamie to please get
strong Jamie I love you my prayers go
out to you and your family please get
well
Martin tweeted this pick with Jamie and
wrote my family and I are lifting you up
in prayer the way I found out about
Jamie was on Martin's page when Martin
posted I pray that Jamie pullster
whatever he's going through
as for Jamie's condition today we're
told he's on the mend healing and
feeling the love while he remains
hospitalized filming on back in Action
continued in Georgia with Cameron Diaz
on set with a stunt double Jamie's team
has not revealed the actor's medical
complication but there's online
speculation he suffered a stroke during
production
speaking of movies for life baby okay
what can you tell us about bad boys we
don't know the plot what can you tell
it has a chance to be the best one of
them all and everybody's doing their
thing and we got we got a lot of the
team back from the last one have you
ever really been in love of course Big
Willy's doing his thing is as always and
so focused and uh it has a chance to be
the biggest one what did it mean to be
here to honor Martin I mean everything
because because Martin Lawrence is
the ultimate performer man he's done so
much for us
especially in in the comedy genre
the 58 year old who starred in five
seasons of the hit show Martin got his
start in stand-up generations of people
still watch the show so now I mean it's
just pure Testament to hard work and
having fun
I didn't know he didn't have a start if
this dude don't have a star they need to
take all of them up off the ground dig
all these damn things up ladies and
gentlemen Martin Lawrence it's that dude
stay mean to you it means the world to
me here's what I understand how is it
taking this long for you to get a song
on a Hollywood Walk of Fame I don't know
but better late than never
foreign